one of the main objectives of the
erasmus+ the EU mobility program for
education training youth and sport is to
boost participants linguistic skills and
offer them support for their language
training with that in mind the unlined
linguistic support feature also known as
OLS has been set up to give a Rasmus
plus participants the chance to have
their language skills assessed whatever
language foreign language they're
learning when they're working studying
or volunteering abroad some participants
will even be able to follow an online
language course to improve the foreign
language even more to find out more
about the live coaching element I'm here
today with Pasco fab she's from the
sauntered along here in Leuven learn if
she's the general public and erasmus+
departments manager thank you very much
for speaking me here today thank you
can you tell me that in a nutshell what
exactly this live coaching element of
the erasmus+ OLF is of course and with
pleasure the erasmus+ oil is life
coaching offers participants who are
enrolled in an OLS language course a
variety of different ways to improve
their language skills life coaching
features have been designed to
complement the self-paced language
course with synchronous and interactive
elements with the Ola LS live coaching
features participants have an
opportunity to attend MOOCs open classes
wait on the model of massive open online
courses to register for tutoring
sessions in very small groups and to
take part in discussions on the forum
dedicated to the language they're
learning like these MOOCs you mentioned
the massive open online courses can you
tell me a bit more about what they are
exactly ok the MOOCs are interactive
educational video is tailored for three
different levels of the CFR the common
European framework for languages a B and
C level a is for those learning to get
by in a language level B is for those
who are a bit more independent and
lastly level c is for
you already feel very comfortable in the
language each Moog has a duration of
around 30 minutes and is based on topics
that are directly related with what
participants can experience during their
Erasmus plus mobility during the MOOCs
participants are encouraged to interact
with both the tutor and all the
participants via the chat function which
makes it a very interactive experience
and can anyone watch these MOOCs or
these videos all the participants who
are enrolled in an ons language course
are able to attend the MOOC sessions in
the language they're learning there is
no limit to the number of MOOCs one
participant can attend currently one
MOOC is scheduled for each language
every week MOOCs are recorded which
means that our spins can freely watch
MOOCs again regardless of whether they
attended the session or not the MOOC
recordings are available on the OLS
platform to view at any time and what
else does the erasmus+
OLS live coaching offer the OLS live
coaching has much more to offer than
just MOOCs it participants want to
improve their language skills with your
help of a tutor they can register for a
tutoring session each tutoring session
addresses a different theme so that
sportsmen can select a topic which
interests them a tutoring session runs
for 30 minutes and a maximum of six
people can register this means that they
get plenty of opportunity to interact
speak and learn participants are able to
sign up for a number of tutoring session
depending on the duration of their
mobility abroad they can attend one
tutoring session for every two weeks
that they're on their Rasmus plus
mobility for example a participant who
is spending 16 weeks on a mobility will
be able to attend a tutoring sessions it
is up to the participants to decide
whether they want to go on or spread
their sessions of the whole period
participants can also connect with
others on the OLS forum dedicated to the
language they are learning forum is
available for each language where
participants are encouraged to interact
speak and learn with others in the
language they are learning for
are moderated by tutors while there to
provide answer to any questions about
the language but participants are so
free to use the forums to discuss the
challenges they may encounter during
their stay abroad and share their
experience with the erasmus+ community I
see well thank you very much for that
pass give it up thank you very much for
watching and have a fantastic erasmus+
you